I don't I don't know how to have that
sense of humbleness coming from a place
of that I love myself though
so DZ calls you her mentor and you
struggle to you see like oh thank you
thank you but you don't actually feel
like you deserve it is a struggle right
find belong within myself the best thing
you can do if you are not willing if you
don't actually feel the receptiveness to
it yet you don't feel like you deserve
it then then lean in on that leaning on
like you know what thank you thank you
so much for saying that I out you have a
really hard time accepting compliments
it's actually really hard for me to hear
the words that you think I'm your mentor
it's something that I'm working through
right now and I want to get better at it
and I really really appreciate you
helping me and saying that that's a way
better answer then thank you that means
a lot it's not an overnight switch it's
an attention that you look towards it's
okay we're gonna get through it you'll
get it but it starts with an intention
and giving Daisy that kind of answer
helps you move one step closer
what's your belong thing as long as you
don't betray yourself right what do you
say I'm you belong anywhere you go as
long as you don't betray yourself of who
you are great so if you don't answer
Daisy the way that's genuine you're
betraying yourself I think the issue of
self-love is one that is super important
for not just entrepreneurs with
everybody watching I think most people
walk through life feeling doubt
insecurity not comfortable in their own
skin and not sure of how to even break
free of it to find their path and they
start living it to me it comes down to
two things one is just a self-awareness
to know who you are to know what you
stand for to know the kind of person
that you want to be and for me that
exercise starts with figure out your one
word most important core value and going
from there and then to once you have the
awareness is actually living it like the
secret to loving yourself is doing the
thing that you want to do even in the
face of judgment of failure of rejection
when you know what you want to do
something but you don't take the action
that haunts you
that's regret for the rest of your life
and that sets the identity for yourself
that I am NOT the kind of person who
follows through and that leads to more
self hate when you don't do the thing
that you want to do you hate yourself
more but if you do the thing that you
want to do you start building that
positive muscle and it's not something
happens overnight it's repetition it's
every single day reminding yourself in
the person you want to be and then
actually taking those actions that leads
to you loving yourself
[Applause]
[Music]
I think people are looking for a quick
escape they're looking for a magical
path through with why people think turn
to drugs and all these other things to
just turn their brain off or if you just
had the self-awareness to know who you
are and then actually take the actions
every single day to live up to it even
though it's scary even though again this
is in the rejection pain fear judgment
doing those things every day if you're
consistent on it then you will learn to
love yourself more altruistic world
domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think unseen
it's a bloody brief life all of you have
the potential for enormous success if
you want to know what Gary Vee DJ Khalid
Oprah and others know about empire
building that most people miss check out
the link in the description for a free
bonus video